oscar isaac stopped by the late show  with stephen colbert and all we have to  say is it involves puppies everybody's  okay yes the host enlisted the actor to  help try to get some of the rescue dogs  adopted by showing them and telling a  little bit about each of them we will  see you next time it's adorable bye-bye  this little one  this is alma  that means soul in spanish  she's a champion marathon runner even  better she's agreed to attach your  fitbit to her caller so now  all those steps can be yours  goose was one of my co-stars in the  movie dune  yeah she she played the most challenging  role of all timmy chalamet's soft fluffy  hair